I'm Lauren I write a column for GQ
called ask a real live lady and I'm here
to answer all the questions you'd feel
too stupid to ask a woman you actually
know
dear ask a real live lady I know I'm not
supposed to send dick pics what if a
girl wants one dear man with a very nice
penis anything short of I want to see a
photo of your erect genitals does not
cut it here dick pics fall under the
category of things you do not do unless
you are absolutely certain the other
person really really wants it look I get
that men are in a constant state of
you're about to see some breasts right
now
doesn't matter if it's 8 a.m. or you're
at your grandmother's funeral so you
figure women must feel the same way
about my gorgeous penis this is an error
in logic if you're going to send me a
picture of your dick better beat a comic
effect like you've drawn glasses and a
mustache on it or it's flaccid flaccid
penises are hilarious
the same way French bulldogs are always
hilarious don't ask me why it's just how
God in heaven design things women like
penises seriously we just don't like
creepy disembodied photos of them sound
like it's part of some sort of normal
flirtation ritual it's not normal a
penis pic is not a first date flower
bouquet okay
[Music]